of this tree immediately held training
of AI systems more powerful than gpt4
for at least 6 months today our three
panelists are co-contributors to end
co-signatories to this letter we will
first start with Max techmark president
of the future of Life Institute and
professor of physics at physics at mit's
NSF AI Institute for artificial
intelligence and fundamental
interactions then we will go to Joshua
bengio founder and scientific director
of Mila Quebec AI Institute and
professor at Montreal University and
then we will go to Emilia javorski
director of multi-stakeholder engagement
at the future of Life Institute after
the remarks we will turn over to
journalists for a quick quick quick
quick question period I will turn the
mic to you Mr techmark
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be with you here today
I'm convinced that artificial
intelligence has an enormous potential
to help life flourish like never before
you know by helping us cure disease
eliminate poverty and solve countless
other problems that have stumped our
human intelligence
and I have helped organize this open
letter because I think there's a real
risk there will squander all of this
wonderful upside if we rush so fast
that we don't keep it safe
that instead get a huge backlash
and uh
basically blow this opportunity the this
letter therefore is not at all directed
against
tech companies or AI research rather our
goal is to help
all the great people in the tech
companies and the academic Community to
just
avoid this very destructive uh
competition driven by commercial
pressure where it's so hard for
companies to resist
doing Reckless things too fast just
because otherwise the other company is
going to do it first
and it's been really heartening to see
how fantastic the response has been when
I just checked we had over 30 000 people
who'd signed this letter
and uh our vetting process is really
struggling to even keep up with it and I
hope this momentum
can really help you
make sure that we get all the upside
without the downside
thank you Mr tegmark I'll now pass the
mic to Mr benjio
welcome everyone
um I I would like to add a few things uh
to what Max just said
so first of all
uh we have basically now reached the
point where there are AI systems that
can fool humans meaning
they can pass the training test which
was considered for many decades
um
kind of Milestone of intelligence and
that is both very exciting because of
all the benefits we can bring
with socially positive applications of
AI but also
I'm concerned that
um powerful tools can also have negative
uses and that Society is not ready to
deal with that and that's essentially
why we are saying
let's
slow down let's make sure that we
um develop better guard rails uh let's
make sure that we discuss these
questions internationally just like
we've done for nuclear power and nuclear
weapons
let's make sure we better understand
these very large systems
that we maybe improve on their
robustness
and the process by which we can audit
them verify that they're safe for the
public
um and we're not seeing like let's stop
research in AI or development of AI but
for these very large systems that are
essentially passing the Turing tests
think uh prudence
uh you know tells us to be careful and
take the time so that we can actually
reap those benefits that would be very
good for society
foreign
executive
thank you Mr bengio I'll now pass the
mic for the final remarks to madame
jaborski
thank you so much and I I'm likely going
to Echo
um what someone what both Yeshua and Max
have already covered but I am a director
of the future of Life Institute uh for
those of you who don't know what our
institute's mission is we're really
focused on enhancing human flourishing
through the safe development of powerful
technology and so as part of our mission
we work to coordinate and mobilize
diverse groups globally across Academia
across industry non-profits and policy
makers to both work on envisioning the
positive Futures we want with technology
but also this key task of identifying
particularly risky applications and
understanding where we need to start
drawing lines on acceptable and
unacceptable uses of Technology my
background is not as an AI scientist I
am a physician and Scientist by training
I come from the world of biology and
that's a field that's done a pretty good
job in its history history of managing
risk and drawing clear lines around
acceptable and unacceptable uses when
you look at things like the biological
weapons convention or the moratorium on
germline genetic engineering and by
drawing it clear lines and pressing
pause in very specific applications has
really helped the field to flourish and
develop countless new therapies for
patients and cure diseases and the
example of nuclear which was sort of
highlighted before we could look to is a
field that wasn't as successful in
drawing those clear lines at the
beginning or mitigating safety and risks
and as a consequence we never really
realized the full positive potential
that peaceful nuclear energy would have
to offer and so today as a global
Community we're faced with this new task
on AI which is arguably going to be one
of the most powerful Technologies
Humanity has ever developed and I think
all of us are shared in the belief that
AI could transform our world for the
unimaginably better for every single
person on this planet through increasing
Prosperity through solving climate
change through work that's been done
that shows AI has the potential to
accelerate the achievement of every
single one of the un's sustainable
development goals
but in order to realize this positive
future we need to avoid making
catastrophic blunders today that not
only have the potential to have really
detrimental effects on our society but
also Doom that positive potential that
AI has to offer along with it so that's
really why today our Institute myself
personally as a science and scientists
and alongside you know the thousands of
others who have signed our open letter
is really this opportunity to say we
need to press pause to ensure that the
most powerful technology that we will
develop is plan for and managed with the
care that's really commensurate to its
potential
thank you thank you all for this this
will start the press conference I'll
invite journalists I want to ask a
question to raise your hands we'll
distribute the questions accordingly
we have 50 minutes so we'll take the
first 40 minutes to take questioning in
English we'll take the last 10 minutes
and 10 to 50 down yeah this case minute
since we have a lot of media we will ask
you to keep to keep that to one question
per journalist by respect for your
colleagues make sure you identify your
name clearly and your outlet clearly as
well so we can distribute you we can
distribute the questions
uh make sure as well you address your
question to the panelists you wanted to
answer uh let's start let's start with
Marisa Carlton from post media if I'm
not mistaken
marister you can go ahead
hello hi
I'm not sure how to get my uh camera on
but I'll go ahead with my question
um you know some reading the letter
might believe that you know it might be
overreacting it might be overstating the
potential that AI has
um to really disrupt Society
um so I'd like to just ask uh Professor
benjiol
um you know whether he you know how he
might respond to somebody who believes
that that the letter is overreacting
um and overstating the potential that AI
has thank you so much
well
um I I think that you have to take the
historical perspective where was AI five
years ago
where it is now so just project yourself
five years into the future
and
um like I don't think we were saying
that
it's necessarily going to be bad but the
risk is sufficiently important
that we all need to start uh dealing
with it and preparing for this takes
time societies don't change quickly
governments don't pass laws quickly
companies don't change their ways of
doing things quickly so it's it's really
time to
um raise the the alarm so that we start
that process
thank you we'll now go to Joey castaldo
from the Global Mail
hi uh thanks for the opportunity
um
I guess my question is you know the the
letter uh talks about how the necessary
level of planning and management with
respect to safety is not happening
um but you know I'm sure if you talk to
any AI company developer researcher you
know they will say safety and risk
mitigation is is a huge priority for us
so I'm just wondering if if you could be
a bit more specific about sort of how
and where you think the industry or the
community is is falling short
um in that regard
that your question is addressed to Mr
bengio
mutant
addressed to whomever wants to uh
whoever I can comment on it
of course all these companies want to do
the right thing and they have safety
teams and and so on but what I've what
I've been told in private by many
leaders in the in the this industry is
that um they're facing this enormous
difficulty because on one hand they want
to do the right thing and take their
time and keep it safe
and not repeat the mistakes that the
civilian nuclear industry did
on the other hand
there is this real race to the bottom
Wherever Whenever they delay their
launch of the of something a little bit
they get slacked from shareholders from
their board they're saying hey but the
other company is eating our lunch
and they need help
from the broader community
to make sure
because no company can slow down alone
exactly
and ultimately it really is the duty of
governments to set the right rules and
and and level the playing field in doing
so
thank you gentlemen uh I am not turning
the mic to Steve ricavina from CBC
yes
um I'm wondering uh this question from
Mr bengio I'm wondering if you could
give some specific examples of what it
is that you're concerned about what
might develop with this technology that
could you know threaten society as is
stated in the letter
yeah there are many risks and some of
our discussed in the latter but let's
say one that I'm particularly concerned
about is uh how these tools could
destabilize democracy we've already seen
that unforeseen sort of social
consequences of things like social media
um we're hard to predict
um but here we have tools that are
essentially starting to master language
and as ararian colleagues were saying in
the New York Times recently language is
the key to how our society structures to
our culture and
those tools could be used to influence
to manipulate people I mean we already
have like advertising and political
advertising but imagine that boosted uh
with a very powerful AI that can speak
to you in a personalized way and
influence you in ways that were not
possible before because we didn't have
that level of uh competence with AI
systems
so so that's one example that
um they're they're you know many
um other issues people are worried about
the job market
um people worry about the use in the
military in particular the fli has
um so I think there are many good
reasons why it's precisely to prepare
against even the things we're not
thinking about that we need this uh
slowing down
thank you Professor
um I don't see more hands in question in
English if there's another if there's
other questions in English maybe we can
do another round in order we can start
back with Marisa
or here I say new hand John John
venaveli Raul sorry for the the
pronunciation you can go ahead
you know what there's just been a lot of
talk in our own Newsroom about some of
the images we saw last week uh the pope
wearing a fleece or a puffer jacket that
was a was a fake arrest images of Donald
Trump that were that were faked are you
can you talk to me a bit about your
concern on that front as well thank you
that's precisely what I was talking
about and answer to the previous
question that we can now manipulate
uh content so it's text but you're right
it's images in a very powerful ways and
it's going to get better or worse
depending on how you want to think about
it in in coming months and years
and it's going to be even a problem for
our courts it's going to be a problem
for the media we need for example to
develop technology to uh like uh be able
to stamp uh genuine content in a way
that is recognizable by machines and by
humans we need to have legislation that
says this content was generated by AI uh
uh and you're not just you know this is
not something real uh that's coming from
a video or a picture or a real person
talking to you so these are examples
where we need faster action
thank you and maybe we can do another
run in English and then we'll switch to
French Marissa from post media if you
have another question you can go ahead
no all right so uh we'll go back to Mr
castaldo from the Globe and Mail
all right is there any other question in
English
to what Joshua said here which I think
is very important
if you look at the big picture of our
democracy right I love the idea of
democracy which is fundamentally that we
humans are able to make decisions by
having a
successful public conversation about
difficult issues and figure things out
together
and that works only if people actually
are living in the same reality not many
parallel realities if people have a
shared understanding of what's actually
going on
and we've already seen early hints as
Joshua mentioned where AI algorithms
powering social media recommender algae
algorithms have have started to create
all these filter bubbles where
people can hardly agree on anything
anymore because of all this filter
bubblinginess and um with the more
powerful abilities of AI to put to
produce fake content that we're seeing
now are very sorts and very persuasive
content
there's there's a real risk that we're
going to just be completely outnumbered
as humans by by content uh by AI
algorithms so we the nightmares a
nightmare scenario here is that we end
up with an online Forum with a public
space basically online where
vast majority of everything is created
by machines and um it becomes harder and
harder for us to even know what's going
on and that is really really
antithetical towards the democratic
ideal I believe that we have
and uh we're building we have to
remember we're building AI by Humanity
for Humanity not for its own sake
yeah and I'd like to add speaking about
democracy that
democracy in Greek means power to the
people
and the danger here
is concentration of power right so
powerful tools
tend to be grabbed by people who have
power to maintain or increase their
power it's just a natural thing it's
always been the case
and there's also being forces in the
past to try to balance that and
democracy is one such tool
um by the way concentration of power
is also bad for capitalism I mean we
need competition but these very large
systems are really right now only
something that a few companies can
afford
um so in in probably just a couple of
countries in the world can do this kind
of thing large scale as well so this
this
is a kind of conflict between democratic
values and the way that these large
tools are being developed that I think
calls for uh you know thinking like I'm
not saying like we have the answers of
how to do these things but we need more
people to get into the discussions to to
to think maybe even like new ways of
organizing our planet our societies
given that those tools are probably here
to stay I think we're not saying we
can't really stop the development of
Science and Technology it's not going to
happen
but we've seen as Emilia was saying that
collectively we are able sometimes
to
um come to terms with uh Technologies
can be dangerous at National and
international levels and we need to do
something like this for AI
thank you Mr Benjo will turn my I'll
turn them back to uh Thomas Tech sorry
about that Thomas I thought you were a
French media
um from Thomas dick from CBC
yeah thanks very much
um Thomas tag here at CBC News perhaps
this question is for Professor tegmark
or anyone who would like to answer what
do you see as the worst case scenario
here
well the worst case scenario is
obviously that we humans gradually lose
more and more control over our
civilization as a as Joshua said
democracy means power to the people so
obviously we don't want to gradually see
too much of it to machines
uh but even before then
there's a real risk that we lose control
to a bunch of
a bunch of this very small number of
unelected people in tech companies who
get an outsized influence over what's
true for example and over how all this
this plays out
uh which would both be bad for
capitalism as Joshua said and and
be bad for for democracy so loss of
control you know we intelligence is what
has made us humans in control of this
planet up until now that we are the
smartest we're not the strongest animal
on the planet or the ones with the
sharpest teeth it's our intelligence
and uh that means it really behooves us
as we build things that are gradually
more important
the first question always has to be how
do we make sure that this we keep
control over this that we can ensure
that those things that are in the human
interest
uh Ms do you have a follow-up question
you can go ahead
no that response was scary enough I
appreciate it perfect
um if there's no more uh oh I see John
as another question in English
um yeah
go ahead essentially again just the the
letter calls for what you want you just
want to pause for six months is that is
that what you're saying don't come out
with gpt5
until at least next year just let sort
of people digest what gbt4 can do and
figure out how to
cope with that
Emilia do you want to feel this one
I mean I can take a first pass at it and
would be interested to hear your Now
show us thoughts about this as well
um I think it cannot be overstated
enough how quickly this is moving and
the fact that the speed element of the
development of AI to Joshua's earlier
point if you look at five years ago
versus now now it's moving so fast that
you even look at six months to a year
ago versus now and the speed at which
the technology is moving is so far
outpacing both our ability to make sense
of it our ability to understand what
risks it pose and our ability to think
towards governance and risk mitigation
options to then employ to mitigate those
risks and so essentially in looking
towards a six-month pause that's giving
us the breathing room and the time to
start to do those activities both in
looking at the technology itself
thinking through how it's going to
affect society and also through putting
in the governance mechanisms as Joshua
said governments move slowly and need
time to make decisions and it's buying
the time that we need to start to get
our hands around this to make sure that
we don't lose control of it so it's
buying time for those conversations
those risk analyzes and those risk
mitigation measures to be put into place
and I also want to add that by time also
for technical Safety Research so if you
look a little bit in more detail about
the great example Emilia gave about
civilian nuclear power right the worst
thing that ever happened
civilian the civilian nuclear power
industry was not that they had too much
regulation it was that they had too
little regulation
what happened the the accidents in for
example Fukushima
Chernobyl Three Mile Island completely
destroyed the industry effectively and
and much of that could actually have
been avoided also with more technical
work they didn't understand well enough
how these systems worked the people in
Fukushima hadn't understood well enough
they were thought through that if
there's a tsunami the water is going to
go to the basement so let's not put the
backup generators there you know they're
I'm confident that there are many
technical improvements that we can make
to today's AI systems that are very
analogous which will avoid problems big
problems before they before they strike
so we're not sitting here trying to make
you all gloomy uh that's not why we're
talking about risks we're talking about
risks so that in advance with the safety
engineering mindset that by thinking
about them now and researching and
figuring out how to avoid them we can
prevent these bad things from ever
happening and getting the upside
I'd like to add a point uh it's very
obvious in my mind that six months is
not going to be enough for society to
find you know all the solutions to deal
with those risks but we have to start
somewhere we have to kind of raise the
flag that we need to pause we need to
think we need to work around Solutions
governance and so on so it's just the
beginning
uh will need probably much more
ambitious and and more thought out
proposals as we move forward
and six months is also really good thing
to start with like Joshua said because
six months is short enough a time that
it'll make no difference whatsoever in
geopolitical competitions or or
competition between companies it's it's
short enough pause that everybody
everybody can
do it without having to worry about
those things
thank you I will take one last question
in English before switching to French so
we'll go with Steve roucavina or one
more question and then we'll go in
French
Steve
okay go ahead okay uh can you hear me
all right yes
um so I'm you mentioned Mr bengio
concentration of power uh you know among
tech companies but some of the
signatories of the letter are people who
have that power in their hands I'm
thinking most notably about Mr musk so
some people might see that as a
contradiction I'm wondering how that
sits with you
oh I'm signing this open letter and not
vouching for everyone who wants to sign
it
so I think the people who signing
disagree with the content of that letter
uh you would have to ask Elon Musk why
he's signing it but you know I can guess
that this is something he's being
concerned about for a long time even
though he's also investing in these
areas but you can also look at you know
other companies that are investing
heavily in AI
um are also worried about these
questions so it's not necessarily a
contradiction
yeah in fact I think it's kind of the
opposite the people who were who worked
mostly most closely with us are
precisely the people who want to see the
risks most clearly
and that's why they're saying in the
alarm and again no company has the power
to stop alone
that's why if you're a company you what
you really want is for everybody to
pause at the same time
thank you if there's more question in
English maybe we can Circle back at the
at the end of this press conference but
for now we'll switch in front of August
okay
um
right next election is directly Canada
is
um
effect
s of
the regular uh foreign
I was truly considers
see um
foreign
thank you this is a
uh
um
dictionary
foreign
um
[Music]
the planet
foreign
media
p
you see the command time uh
um
before
me
is
foreign
Valencia
right
um foreign
[Music]
because
um
that's gonna pull forward
in Japanese
foreign
uh
yes sir uh next I'd like to hear you on
this about
how this kind of initiative
might help
Russia or China
that are already using AI
um to gain more ground
uh you're muted
first of all I think I think it's quite
obvious that the
there's no way that China or Russia can
catch up with the West in six months so
even if they were to try this this
wouldn't really make any difference
geopolitically second I I think that the
loss of control that we all worry about
is something that probably bothers the
Chinese government even more than
Western governments because they really
like control
and you can see for example the Ernie
chat bot that was recently launched by
Baidu I believe right very quickly got
severely reigned in by the Chinese
government because they felt they didn't
have enough control over what it was
saying what it was doing and so I
actually think that um
they the Chinese government does not
have an incentive just egoistically to
forge ahead too fast with these very
unpredictable systems
thank you Mr tegmark
um I'll go to Mr Malik from Reuters and
then I'll go back to Mr benassia I have
only two more hands left so if you have
a question and you're a member of the
media just a quick reminder if you can
pull the Press on the hand button we'll
give you the we'll give you a question
one question one follow-up I'm sorry
about that just one more comment on on
this issue with West versus China you
know probably the best recipe for the
West to lose the long-term competition
against China is if we completely
destabilize our own democracy
thank you Mr Malik you can go ahead
yeah hi uh uh thanks for taking my
question and uh thanks to the panel uh
uh a great uh set of points being made
here I I just have one question see
we're talking about AI models that deal
with content uh you know that is uh the
series of uh AI generative we had seen
come out I just wanted to take your view
on AI that is being developed for other
use cases and here I mean let's say
Tesla's autopilot uh over there do you
recommend a similar kind of pause for
development of AI for other use cases
other than content uh and just what's
your view on that uh there's a quick
part two of this question how did you
all arrive at uh six month pause uh you
know what what informs that that
timeline is is accurate perfect for for
us catching up you know the regulations
and and research catching up with uh use
cases for this AI just these two
questions thank you so much
Joshua do you want to take a crack maybe
Emilia
I think
perhaps I'll start with the the latter
part of your question the why six months
I think six months is a time frame that
as other panelists have spoken to is
something that's feasible and doesn't
necessarily contain sort of the
geopolitical constraints of downside to
putting an indefinite
um pause
um it's an ample amount of time to start
the process again as Joshua said we are
not going to figure this all out in six
months but it does give us some
Breathing Room in order to start to
tackle these questions and start to
think on on these issues
um so in terms of like where where can
we what was the amount of time that did
not have a tremendous amount of downside
risk associated with it and push back
and was feasible but long enough to get
us to start to think about these issues
and get our hands on what it is we're
actually dealing with with how we
arrived at the six month time point in
terms of AI applications and other areas
I I will leave that to yahshua and Max
an area that I worked um quite a bit on
is applications of AI in the military
and specifically looking at AI
integration into weapon systems and that
is something we also have been quite
vocal on in terms of the needs of
prohibitions and regulations for that
specific use case but that is slightly
different than the pause that we're
referring to with the large language
model training
um maybe I will add a few things with
respect to the first part of the
question
so so no I mean we're we're talking
about the huge AI systems that have been
developed recently
using
um large language models
and the reason for that focus is this is
where it's most scary right we're
talking about a short-term thing we're
not saying let's stop everything going
on in Ai and in fact my personal uh kind
of opinion that I have expressed in the
recent uh chapter in in a book that Mila
and UNESCO edited and was presented last
week
is that we need to double down on
investment in AI in socially beneficial
areas like healthcare and environment
social justice
and by the way these there's never I
mean there isn't that kind of level of
amount of data and many of these
applications these systems are very
specialized so the kinds of risks we're
talking about for example for democracy
don't really
typically exists uh in those
applications we do need to have you know
the same guard rails for everyone but
really in the same way that the European
and the Canadian legislation are uh
carefully stating that we need to
distinguish high risk systems from lower
risk systems and the level of scrutiny
and uh and so on that that are needed
are different
um so here we focus on like the the very
very top of the scale here that is the
most concerning but
I don't think we should stop or even
slow down
um the many other applications that are
clearly not posing any risks
um but like where where in the future we
should put the line well that's why you
know we need governance to uh in
consultation with civil society and and
scientists
um you know
put those put those boundaries
thank you to all of you and we'll go to
Chloe's on their voice I don't I think
you're from CBC
Radio Canada
foreign
[Music]
dope
foreign
[Music]
yourself so I'm guessing you have one
last question
to thank the panel uh thanks for the
answer earlier no worries
and I can ask in English also what was
the reaction you've got uh the bigger
from the from the big players in this
industry up to now
I can speak to that briefly here
there are two kind of reactions the kind
of reactions you see openly that they
tweet and and say to media and then
there's also the private reactions when
like when I personally talk to them
and um
privately
I've mostly gotten very positive
reactions because again these companies
feel that they cannot slow that slow
down alone
and are very grateful that there's
something in motion now that might let
make everybody slow down at the same
time if you are working very very hard
to build a new technology
of course you want it to be safe of
course you wanted to work and and of
course you want breathing room to make
sure that it's going to work before you
unleash it to the world I was also
wondering if it's before we end the
press conference we've almost all the
questions have been about risk and
downsides I was wondering if we could
maybe
give Emilia the final word to cheer us
all up by saying a few more words about
all the upside that we can have if if we
get this right
yeah I I think thank you Max I think
that's something that is really at the
core of the mission of the future of
Life Institute is the whole conversation
we're having today around risk
mitigation and thinking about when to
press pause is because of the positive
potential that this technology has to
offer for our society and for sort of
the future of humanity and the future of
what it means to be a human being as a
whole
um so from from our perspective the
reason we want to regulate and the
reason we want to avoid these sort of
dire outcomes is because we want to
realize the positive potential that the
technology has to offer and at the
future of Life Institute in addition to
the work we do on risk mitigation we
also have a program which I lead which
is our flourishing Futures initiative
which is really thinking through and
imagining how can we actually use AI to
solve the problems that we have today
and to forge future and and having that
conversation to be one that is inclusive
and things through
um what are all the different ways and
paths that AI can take us to better
places so those are the conversations we
want to keep having and pressing pause
and drawing lines today is what's going
to help make that possible
thank you Amelia for those last words
I'm just gonna take one minute maybe if
there's another member of the media that
did not ask a question I would like to
ask a question now is your chance if you
want to raise your hand otherwise this
will conclude this press conference
all right so there's nobody there's
nobody raising their hands so thank you
very much to all our panelists today and
this concludes our press conference if
you have any requests you can send us an
email thank you merci beaucoup
thank you thank you very much Mercy